it's great to Welcome to the program
today Allison Butler who's a contributor
to the media and me a guide to critical
media literacy for young people and also
the director of the media literacy
certificate program at my undergraduate
alma mater the University of
Massachusetts in Amherst Allison it's
really great having you on I appreciate
it
thanks so much I'm really excited to be
here so I mean I guess let's just start
with something it's a simple question
the answer may not be so simple but it's
something I I talk about a lot media
literacy I think should start being
taught at the latest in seventh grade to
everybody probably fifth grade is even
better it's pretty rare particularly
that public schools have media literacy
programs is it as simple as it's just
not a priority to those creating the
curricula or is there more to why it's
not commonly taught
I think there's more commonly taught and
I would you know raise your fifth to
seventh grade to say we need to start an
early childhood education our children
are exposed to the media within you know
immediately
um and certainly with social media we
can learn a lot about them before
they're born uh their identities are out
there really early on uh I think yes it
is something that is really can be
understood to be difficult to add to the
curriculum and part of the reason why
it's difficult is we don't have
formal training formal education for
people who want to teach media literacy
so oftentimes teachers have to kind of
figure it out on their own and goodness
knows they have enough to do so to ask
them to add more is arduous part of our
work part of my work is to say we need
teacher education and media literacy
yeah that's interesting because the I
remember that there were these kind of
one-off classes in middle and high
school that were interesting I remember
one called like Transportation power and
energy which was really interesting it
didn't really fit anywhere and the
teacher who taught it was not certainly
an expert in that field and sort of had
to figure it out as as he went and so it
does seem that part of the problem as
you're pointing out is it's not common
that the teacher base is necessarily
equipped to teach media literacy
correct I talk with teachers all the
time who say that they're really
interested in bringing in the study of
the media to their classrooms
particularly because they see how glued
to their devices their students are but
then they're at a loss for how to teach
it formally I think also sometimes like
you mentioned these kind of one-off
classes they can often be seen as like
what you get to do when you're done with
what you're supposed to be studying yes
yes absolutely which is sure that's
that's I mean there's value in that
right there's absolute value in that I
wouldn't say that that was prob that was
that that's a bad idea but I do think
it's bad if it's the only way that we're
teaching it because our media are so
infused in our lives why would we then
think about educating them as like an
add-on or
um as something to do when you're done
the important stuff
by the time people get to you so at the
college level what do you find are the
most common blind spots in being able to
look at media and think about it
critically in terms of you know we we
often hear really young kids can't tell
the difference between advertising and
content for example or
um people can't necessarily distinguish
between whether they're watching news or
opinion programming is a more common one
for older people what are the most
common blind spots by the time people or
college age and get to you
I I mean I'd say there's probably two
really big ones that can then Branch out
into so many more one for the most part
by the time they get to me they're
pretty good at understanding the content
but they don't know where that content
comes from they don't know the power
behind the content and that's part of a
lot of the work that I do and that my
colleagues and I do in um in the media
and me is say it's not just about what's
on the screen or just what we're hearing
the actual Powers behind the scenes we
have to talk about ownership production
and distribution and I'd say connected
to that but the other big area is Again
by the time students come to my
classroom as college students freshmen
through seniors they're really invested
in media they're involved in a lot of
media they have multiple social media
accounts but have no clue where their
information is going uh social media is
a huge tool of surveillance massive
amounts of data Gathering probably safe
to say that most if not all of us zip
through those terms of service zip
through those privacy documents don't
read the truly truly fine fine print and
all the paragraphs of legalese we sign
off on them it's the only way that we
have access to these platforms and yet
we have no idea where our information is
going what's happening to it the one
clue that we get is often as soon as we
search for something
quite quickly after that an
advertisement for that very thing will
pop up we gave away the data that let
that happen do you look pretty dangerous
do you find that over the last 10 years
the usage of social media among 18 to 22
year olds has changed in any appreciable
way I mean one of the things I've read
is that on average people's use of
Facebook is going in the direction of
fewer friends and tending towards people
you really know rather than a larger
circle of friends so like that's a
change in terms of average Facebook use
but do you see that the 18 to 22 year
olds are thinking of their social media
presences differently than maybe a
decade ago oh absolutely I mean I think
maybe some of what's going on with young
people in Facebook is that they I mean
you know once people my age got onto
Facebook it became a lot less
interesting for young people and you
know now that Grandma's there right kind
of makes it less fun I guess
um so I understand from my students that
they use something like Facebook almost
more for like School connections or
school projects as a way of connecting
with people
um but I think that in terms of their
own personal use of social media it's a
source of anxiety uh that it's meant at
least at some points for them to be fun
and as its name for it to be social but
it can be remarkably anti-social you're
often pretty isolated with it and
certainly some of those comparisons
against the beautiful airbrushed images
are incredibly difficult uh but they're
also entering a world where they're
expected to know how to use this
professionally and so that anxiety is
not just about self but it's also about
their preparation for their future and
what's like sort of what's to come next
and I think in some ways met like like
all of us do with certain areas of our
life is that young people can kind of
become their own worst enemies they will
be upset or concerned about once it's
introduced to them about some of these
surveillance Technologies but one of the
biggest things that's happening these
days is that young people use the find
my app where they are constantly
tracking where their friends are and
what I hear from my students is they use
it so that when they don't text a friend
back their friend knows it's because
they're in a class where they're not
supposed to have their phones on so as
much as they might get frustrated by
being surveilled they also are
participating in that speaking of phones
in class
um I last taught as an adjunct at Boston
College in 2017 and it was a once a week
class so it was just like listen we're
here one so we I don't want to see any
phones period just absolutely no phones
they're on laptops I don't know what
they're doing on the laptops I don't
really want to get involved in that but
it was just like there should never be a
phone that's out how much of an active
distraction is whether they're on social
media or not the phones in the classroom
right now what's your sense of that
oh I think they're a huge distraction
it's so hard for us not to look at our
phones I actually have a policy in my
class that unless there is a documented
accommodation need no cell phones no
computers and stop looking at your smart
watches that were here to discuss ideas
there's no tests in my class there's no
final exam this is about engaging with
each other and engaging with with our
discussions and most of them can't
really put their phones away they sort
of turn them over on their desks I will
watch them get up and leave the room for
a few moments and I'm assuming they're
checking their phones but they don't
want to get like caught checking it in
class and at the end it there's there's
stress about that and some of them do
get frustrated with me but at the end of
the semester the consistent commentary I
get is this is the one class I actually
paid attention to
um because I couldn't be distracted
that's interesting that's interesting to
to get kind of back to the media
literacy part a couple other things to
talk about
when it comes to how do I identify a
trustworthy source
anybody who's been in this field any
length of time we we know about all of
the things that are often said and it
they tend to involve research they tend
to evolve you know it's not oh hey
here's an article I just found I'm very
in 30 seconds going to be able to do all
of the things that on paper we often say
here's how you identify whether a source
is trustworthy what's the lowest hanging
fruit that any news consumer can employ
to try to suss out whether an article or
a video clip or whatever the case may be
is coming from a source that can be
trusted
I think the first thing to do is is an
author mentioned because if an author
isn't mentioned who knows how that got
put together it could be PR
um do you know the website right does it
and look closely at the website because
websites are easily manipulated so you
could have like you know New York Times
Dash com dot Gmail or you know right and
then you're like wait I saw the New York
Times but then it's something totally
different right um so truly look at the
ending of the website almost of the URL
almost before looking at the beginning
does it look like a real website
can you get back to that article without
two I mean look at everything is going
to have pop-up ads but if it's the ones
that are just like overtaking your
screen can you learn more about the
author you don't have to like what they
say but can you actually learn more
about this person and if not I would be
suspicious about whether or not that
person is either actually a person
um or you know potentially a bot or so
on and so forth or if it's somebody
who's kind of hiding behind some other
sort of idea or some other sort of
message so those would be the absolute
first things I would also say be really
cautious about maybe the next level
would be really cautious about what you
click on on social media social media
platforms are not news platforms we can
share news on them
but they are not news platforms so if we
you know like if we talk to young people
who say like oh I get most of my news
from Twitter well no you don't you get
information on Twitter that somebody
might have shared right that might be
news you're finding links on Twitter
exactly yeah you're finding links on
Twitter another thing that seems
critical that I tell people is TR make
an attempt to get to the primary source
if there actually is one because there's
so you know there will be situations
where not to pick on any of these
particular news outlets but you'll see a
raw story article with a headline and it
will quote Newsweek it's actually a
Newsweek article that they are
summarizing and editorializing you go to
the Newsweek article and Newsweek
actually says as reported by The
Washington Post and so you drilling down
to where did this actually come from
seems like a fundamental first step in
evaluating it because really all Raw
Story might be doing is rewriting an
article you can't really ascertain the
truth of the matter you can ascertain
whether it's honestly Rewritten but not
the the underlying reporting and so
finding the primary source seems really
important a lot of people may not
realize the difference between a
Rewritten blog style article and the
reporting
yep absolutely and that's true I mean I
think one thing to you're absolutely
right is who is being sourced and our
source is being named are those the
primary sources is you know if something
says something to the effect of like
research shows well where's that
research I should be able I might not be
able to distill the research myself that
quickly but I should be able to access
the research I also think that
especially in the previous uh
presidential Administration the idea of
unnamed sources right what does it mean
for a source to go a name for some for
some stories that is really legitimate
there are dangerous issues why
somebody's name out there could be a
problem but for others it's it's a it's
a kind of a circuitous Route Around
citing your sources so part of our work
in the media knee and part of our work
in critical media literacy is
evidence-based research we want to
provide evidence ourselves and we want
people to be looking for evidence
themselves there was a even confusion
during the Trump era of when we talk
about an anonymous source are they known
to the reporter and there were countless
instances where people misunderstood
that even the reporter didn't know who
the person was when the reporter did
it's just they weren't they weren't
naming them and that's a critical
difference
absolutely absolutely 100 we've been
speaking with Allison Butler contributor
to the media and me a guide to critical
media literacy for young people also
director of the media literacy
certificate program at UMass Allison
really great having you on I appreciate
your time
thanks so much David it was great
chatting with you